thor love and thunder is an incredible
cacophony of sight and sound it is so
big it is so grandiose it is so
taikawatiti and i think that's one of
the great strings of the film this is
the most tatastic a film can be it has a
lot more dna with jojo rabbit or boy
than anything in the rest of the mcu and
much in the same way that multiverse
madness is a sam raimi film first and
then an mcu film i feel the same about
this it is
really bittersweet and it's humor it has
a humorous melancholy to it that i think
taika specializes in that i really
really enjoyed it's a bit of a darker
film than i think a lot of people
anticipate and uh that ties into the
jason aaron asadra beast run that this
is largely based off of and gore within
that run is absolutely incredible
christian bale brings
such a different take to a marvel
villain here whereas thanos and
killmonger especially are both
psychologically driven in that you're
afraid to identify with them you
definitely understand to a point where
both thanos and killmonger are coming
from and you get the same with gore but
from a different perspective and in a
different way
and that is more chilling it's more
outwardly terrifying it's almost a more
horror villain take i also think that
you get to see thor odin son in a very
different way here and what they're able
to do with it being a love story as
they've talked about press quite a bit
is so beautiful and so interesting and
there's nothing quite like chris
hemsworth's thor like chris hemsworth is
able to bring
such comedy with
pathos in it like you feel
for him while laughing with him and then
you've got i think
some of the best chemistry we've seen in
the mcu with him and jane foster
this is what natalie porton was hired
for this is why natalie portman was
supposed to be jane foster is the
relationship in this movie now their
relationship is so beautiful and
intricate
and full of depth and character if you
want giant side of the van
80s action you're going to be very happy
tessa thompson gets more time to be
tessa thompson there's so much
going on with her as valkyrie and
there's so much that they were able to
do with her character that the other
films hadn't got a chance to yet that it
really really fleshes out her character
in a way that i wasn't necessarily
expecting i think valkyrie is the mvp of
the film for me i want to give anything
away so i'm gonna
wrap this up i love that the trailers
didn't give
any of the things that some marvel
trailers lately i've been giving away i
went to this
knowing the comic books and i went into
this knowing
i don't know five minutes of footage and
that's what i'd recommend you do as well
it's very special it's very heartwarming
i
still struggle admittedly with the
pacing and some of the tone choices as
much as i enjoy them it does definitely
bring me into a different headspace
with the character that i usually feel
with the comic book and to be honest it
took me a bit with spider-man as well
this isn't how i perceive thor but
that's not on the filmmakers that's you
know my take on the character so see it
enjoy it it'll be fun to talk about when
we do our spoiler review and the end
though
probably my favorite
last five minutes
probably my favorite
button to wrap up a film go see thor
love and thunder it is a goddamn delight